so the hashtag Kanye West is over party
or like is canceled was trending because
the clip that was released of Taylor
Swift saying that it's speaking to Kanye
saying that like she approved of his
lyric I made that [ __ ] famous in his
song - I wrote a couple years ago he
said that he called her and there was
more footage that was released recently
that basically shows he he told her a
part of the verse but he didn't tell her
that part and what didn't Kim say oh I
knew she was gonna do this so I posted
this I record this somebody and she
posted right she posted it but she
didn't post this part and this part came
I haven't seen this what is this have
you seen this is the call so my next
single
I wanted you to tweet it it's the it's a
good fries to drop as a good Friday song
so that's what I'm calling you that I
wanted you to put the song out she's
uncomfortable well they did point by
Taylor Swift why am i posting result the
reason why it would be happen is because
it has a very controversial line at the
beginning of the song about you alright
so it says and the song is so so dope
and I'm literally sat with my wife with
my home management team with everything
and try to rework this line I've thought
about this line for eight months I've
had this line I'll try to rework it
every which way and the the original way
that I thought about it is the best way
but it's the most controversial way so
it's it's gonna go eminem a little bit
so can you brace yourself for a second
oh sure liked it alright yeah it's it
way too good you sounds sad
no I don't think it's me keep in mind
she's only 18 here okay
it's said I don't think she was 18 she's
like well in her mid-20s but on the
first play she's like 30 now if so uh
still young heard it yes she was like
huh what that's too crazy bah bah bah
and then like when ninja from Dee at
work heard it he was like oh my god this
is the craziest [ __ ] this is why I was
really selling just let me hear it this
is so yeah I'm already uncomfortable
Brian I just want to give you some
premise of that right okay so it says to
all my Southside [ __ ] that know me
best
I feel like Taylor Swift might owe me
sex okay yeah oh well this is the thing
I'm calling you because you got an army
you own a country of [ __ ] two
billion people he didn't say why I made
that [ __ ] face yeah he didn't say that
what did you have that written at the
time I am NOT that's what people don't
know maybe it's run off like but still
but yeah that footage is realer I might
owe me sex but he said I feel like
Taylor and me might smite have sex well
that's not the problem
after that he goes cuz I made that [ __ ]
famous yeah yeah what Taylor Swift was
upset about and accept and was talking
about in her Grammy Award speech but um
yeah yeah I had but my whole thing is is
I just need some more details I'm not
defending Tunney but cuz did you have
that line written at the time yeah I
guess I'm doin the polite thing called
everything that no one really know well
it's really hard for someone like Taylor
Swift then to kind of like you know and
somebody asked you that and you feel
uncomfortable but you're embarrassed to
be uncomfortable just go then that's
that's the problem - you know you
understand how like like certain women
would be like well I deal with that all
the time right because you can say it'd
be like if if say say you guys were
listening and somebody was talking about
some insult to Asians okay even like the
Saturday Night Live thing with a guy
used the word [ __ ]
you guys under under pressure because
we're here you might not express your
outrage on camera or it might be
uncomfortable for you to say you're feel
offended by that it might be feeling
maybe some people would be like I don't
like a scene I don't like it but I don't
want but that's a little different I'm
saying I'm saying that like for Taylor
it's hard for her to say to him I don't
like that he's already making it so but
that's I'm in the point because the the
point is is he lied about what a line
was him just saying me and Taylor might
have sex she's like all right I guess
that's not she goes that's not mean I
would give her [ __ ] here here's the
problem is he lied about if you would
have said and then I say yeah might have
sex cuz I made that [ __ ] famous she's
like Nike can't but make up [ __ ] famous
right also Tanja should know this being
the business he should have went through
her team can soon as I went to her
manager this woman even got the tape
right they may like get the [ __ ] at it
everybody's not and not only that keep
in mind also there's a there's a second
violation by Kanye West and Kim
Kardashian which was then to shame
Taylor for coming out and saying but
that's not what you said yeah and then
then then Kim Kardashian said oh is it
snakes called orous name no now and all
is redundant yeah that's right
Kardashian went hard in the paint again
super hard so it's like oh but wait
that's that's interesting so you you
knew the truth and you still sold her
down who posted that that clip I know I
believe it was her sister wasn't it I
thought it was I thought it was Kris
Jenner what one of the Jenner's did I
don't know hosted this clip yes I had
the whole no way I think so I would she
do that that's what I read we did my
promo from so so these things come out
man at the end of the day it's really
interesting god that's such a bad look
for them that's such a bad look yeah you
can't lie everything I watch half the
documentary on Taylor Swift now if you
were if you were Taylor Swift's manager
be in that situation and the lyric came
out I made that [ __ ] famous if you were
her manager what would you tell Taylor
to do in that situation
ignore nothing that's right that's how I
feel don't even bring attention to it
don't tell me you okay didn't know that
all right cool man there oh wow oh wait
it's the JIT national snake day they
have holidays for everybody uh
everything these days John Jesus Christ
Kimmy Kenya that's this big Kimmy Connie
the most respectable people in the Shu
they lied about telling 16 and Taylor
got a lot of [ __ ] for this man ah
people keep sailor a lot of [ __ ] water
why don't that we'll have you seen her
year of the documentary she suffers from
horrible depression for it stays awful
how could you not how could you not man
and by the way major stalking and [ __ ]
like that which they don't talk about
she talked about it in that documentary
for you a little bit about somebody
breaking into her home yeah dude
really dangerous people John having had
that yeah God but what a terrible thing
is if you're Kim and Kanye to like what
more do you guys need why would you need
to shame this 25 year old with this
really bad much money do you mean how
much Fame do you need embarrassing
tonight what you feel it's just I hate
Barris it's just that it's it's also
like evil like Hollywood not great [ __ ]
man agree yeah you just can't lie about
that stuff I don't know man I don't know
but again how much did well I don't know
maybe I'm gonna give enough crowd Z and
say did Kim Kardashian post that
thinking maybe they just showed her that
clip was she actually there when he
called her or did did kind of just show
her that clip it's a lot of different
Kanye's the Pro out of all this honey's
that's right she mighta there might have
been my kid might have been going on
what Connie honey would look at this
video this me call her her been like
what the [ __ ] really give me this I'm
gonna post this exact post it he's like
yeah do that girl that's possible
till the whole out of it all this like
the bad guys kinda that's [ __ ] up dude
I agree right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
Oh [ __ ] business